i think i found someone to produce my  next album  his name's von daniels it says he was  tried for murder he was acquitted  come in mr daniels i'm glad you're here  gray this is my girlfriend  charlie i  get the creams since you got here your  music gets sunny  that's beautiful i can smell it all over  you  and something primal you need to use  that  there's nothing that you have to hide  from me  i suffer from hallucinations  i hallucinate that i'm turning into an  animal  [Music]  what's wrong you okay we're leaving  this place is doing something it's not  this place  you can't run away from your destiny i  don't know  it's not safe for you here  do you want to be a predator or do you  want to be praying  from everyone's eyes  [Music]  you